if i were 85 years old and i got to go
through a time machine and be back in my
body as i am now to experience my life
from my 85 year old self it's
dramatically shifted how i see
everything so let me walk you through it
i've struggled to feel grateful for most
of my life it's not that i don't have
things to be grateful for i have tons of
things to be grateful for but i don't
feel gratitude and so i've tried a lot
of different practices to try and feel
gratitude you know the journals and the
daily meditations and things like that
but they've never really stuck that's
not to say that they don't work for some
people but i want to share with you in
this video is one of the most powerful
perspective changes that i've ever
experienced
if you don't know who i am my name is
alex romozy i'm the managing partner at
acquisition.com which is a portfolio of
companies that does over 100 million
dollars a year and i have nothing to
sell you i make these videos because i
hope that you make all the money in the
world and you experience all the joy
that you possibly can in the process i
have spoken in the past about the frame
of the veteran which i won't recap here
but it's really just having different
frames or perspectives through which to
see circumstances so that you can
improve your experience recently i've
been trying to toy with one that would
create gratitude there's a clip that
went pretty viral not that long ago it's
also my number one tweet of all time
which is when i was 20 i wanted to be a
millionaire now that i'm a millionaire i
want to be 20. when i'm 85 years old and
in my mind i imagine i will be a
multi-billionaire at that point i know
that i would give up everything that i
have of material wealth just to be poor
and 20 again i call this the frame of
the grandfather or the grandfather frame
and it works like this if you've ever
looked at pictures from your past and
you look at where you grew up or you
look at you know your old room or you
look at a picture of you with old
friends doing something we tend to feel
these feelings of nostalgia and i tried
to quantify like what is nostalgia so to
me nostalgia is gratitude in the present
for past circumstances for whatever
reason we're able to kind of look past
all of the kind of minutia of how we
were feeling our moods and we're able to
kind of like see big picture the things
that we are grateful for take a pause
here i'm sure all of us have tons of
childhood [ __ ] and things that we wish
were different and blah blah blah blah
but there are still elements of our past
our childhood our adolescence our
teenage years our college years whatever
it is right where you feel grateful some
of you guys are superstars and are
always grateful for everything and i'm
you know i'm jelly i don't roll that way
it's not like i wake up and i'm like man
i just want to count my lucky stars like
i just don't that's just not how i
function and i've been trying this on
and i i hope you do too because it's
been it's been really like improving my
life i tried to do this i wake up
thinking to myself if i were 85 years
old and i got to go through a time
machine and be back in my body as i am
now to experience my life
from my 85 year old self seeing it again
if i wake up and i feel my body and i'm
like oh
this is so nice i don't have all the
joint pain ah my wrists don't have
arthritis and then i wake up and i'm
like i remember when we used to live
here even when i looked at layla this
morning i was thinking to myself man
like this is my wife right at the
beginning of our marriage you know we're
only six years in we wake up and we walk
over to you know to have our coffee in
the morning which we always do and i'm
like isn't this so nice i remember we
used to have coffee here together this
is great and i look out the window look
how young vegas looks it doesn't have
all these buildings and these flying
cars like it does now it's it's so
underdeveloped compared to what it is
today and i feel gratitude for an
external just environment which i would
never really think that but i know that
my 85 year old self will totally
appreciate those things as i'm going
through the day applying that frame also
to business where i can see that you
know the ceos of our companies and the
people that work within our holding
company acquisition.com they're stressed
about things and in my mind i'm thinking
ah isn't this cool that we get to do
this together isn't that fun isn't that
neat look how cute that is it is the
most powerful frame that i've
encountered i think the reason it's so
powerful is one it operates almost
entirely from a frame of gratitude that
for me i can feel for whatever reason
gratitude journals the meditations
things like that like i don't feel that
but thinking about my 85 year old self
being able to re-experience life through
my 32 year old body it's really shifted
how i see things and also decreases the
amount of anxiety and stress i have over
outcomes because i'm like this isn't
going to matter in the long run i also
think it helps from a business the term
loosely but like a business wisdom
perspective because when you think about
the decisions you think about it within
the larger context of your life and
you're not like oh yeah i'm gonna make
that short term dollars because you're
like i'm 85. i don't have anything to
prove you know what i mean you think
about like the really stressful things
that you've had happen in your past i
feel nostalgia for the sleeping on the
floor that i did at my gyms for how
tired i used to be at the end of the day
of taking 20 plus consults for months
and months and months on end and rather
than feeling stressed about it or
resenting the fact that i have to do it
like i get to do this i get to make
videos talking to a camera look at my 32
year old self go trying to make his
content trying to help other
entrepreneurs like isn't that cool if i
had to characterize seasons of my life i
would say i was very angry as a teenager
and young adult and then i went from
angry to being aware of the deficit
between where i was and what i
considered to be happiness from there i
kind of switched to what i have
affectionately called the [ __ ] happiness
mantra which i lived for a very long
period of time which was i stopped
trying to optimize for happiness at all
and just really stopped thinking about
it all together which i think
moved me closer to something that i
would consider to be joy you can be
joyful independent of circumstance
because joy is from within happiness
tends to come from external right it
comes from circumstance and i think when
we look at the grandparents or at least
the people that are older that i aspire
to be they just have an internal joy
they have gratitude for being able to
live it one last time because the end of
the day like
it is our last time i'm being real here
like i've had a guy that i graduated
with died a few months ago
and um he was a really successful guy
really smart kid did really well i mean
this is really dark but he got randomly
murdered
and you know he had grand plans for his
life
and i think to myself i'm like you know
tomorrow really isn't guaranteed thank
you for your attention i know you have a
lot of places that you can put it and i
am grateful that you chose to share the
moment with me so
most nation appreciate you guys
bye